c'est la polémique qui a enflammé les
réseaux sociaux et les médias cet été
les jets privés énorme pollueurs sont
pointés du doigt depuis plusieurs
semaines les trajets en jet privé dont
certaines personnalités use et parfois
abusent lors de leurs déplacements
personnels homme d'affaires star
politique s'ils ont pris l'habitude de
voyager à bord de ce petit avion tout
confort alors de l'urgence climatique le
jet privé fait beaucoup moins rêver les
vols privés ont une empreinte carbone de
5 à 14 fois plus importante qu un avion
commercial est 50 fois plus important
qu'un train est sur internet leurs
trajets sont scrutés à la loupe par les
internautes et le célèbre conte
celebrity jetta et grâce aux flèches
draghi un voyage de 14 minutes pour
drake en juillet dernier 12 minutes pour
kylie jenner et seulement 9 minutes pour
elon musk qui préfère laisser la tesla
au garage
des chiffres qui font bondir surtout
quand on connaît l'empreinte carbone de
tel trajet ils vivent sur une autre
planète or n'y a pas de planète il y en
a qu'une cette semaine la polémique a en
fait un peu plus lors d'une conférence
de presse du psg où son entraîneur
christophe galtier qui n mbacké était
interpellé sur les déplacements en jet
privé de leur équipe pourra très heureux
d'être avec vous ce matériau on a parlé
avec
la société qui organise le déplacement
en train de voir si on peut pas se
dépasser en char à voile une réponse qui
a provoqué de nombreuses critiques
depuis mardi et qui a suscité la
réaction de la ministre des sports
abelli oued à castéra sur twitter
monsieur kalt c'est vous nous avez
habitués à des réponses plus pertinentes
et plus responsable on en parle
prochainement le gouvernement entend
faire des propositions pour réguler
l'usagé des jets privés alors aller
retour en jet privé les stars
doivent-elles être sanctionné
omar harfouch a enjoint est
juste quelques cibles quand même parce
qu'évidemment nokia shorts deux taylor
swift qui arrive en tête avec son pas le
code 970 voyage en un an ces 8 293
tonnes de carbone c'est l'équivalent de
huit mille personnes et après bankai
leur jenner du clan kardashian elle
c'est pire que tout son propre avion
elle c'est un boeing 747 c'est ça son
rang son jet à l docu plein plein plein
de people elon musk également aussi bref
tous ils sont passés il ya des sites
deux tracker un peur pour voir justement
ce qu'ils font combien ils dépensent ça
a été un peu le scandale de cette année
jusqu'à on a vu qu il n aime pas p et
galtier qu on pouffe et de rire
lorsqu'on a parlé du train plutôt que de
l'avion voilà je vous laisse en penser
ce que vous voulez il a pouffé de rire
quand il a parlé de char à voile pas de
sens non pas du tout bon pas du tout
parce que la vanne de char à voile elle
arriva alors l'unique bébé là on va dire
demande à quelqu'un qui a un job il est
à lui et lui quand il veut dîner il
n'appelle pas au beurre il appelle pas
le ritz d'abord la belle taxi milanais
chat et monte dans son jet et il va
bouffer une bouillabaisse à nice c'est
bien ça omar oui sauf que j'aime pas la
boue arrière ramassée désolé pour la
bouillabaisse ça oui non mais on fait un
faux procès en fait aux jets privés
l'aviation privée elle représente à
peine 0 04 % d'émissions de co2 dans le
monde oui
0,04 sait rien du tout l'aviation civile
en général avec les avions de transports
l'aviation commerciale et tout avec les
jets privés ça représente à peine 2,1
pour cent des émissions de co2 donc
c'est vraiment c'est vous que ça prend
des villes peut-être l'idée peut-être
que normalement on va dire allez un
milliardaire
ma grand mère me dit toujours si un jour
tu as une porsche arrête-toi opio
passage piéton pour bien laisser passer
les gens tu dois être un exemple est ce
que vous comprenez que vous êtes un
petit peu un symbole payet il y en a qu
elle est reçue celle a pris son avion
pour 12 minutes 12 minutes que saïd
école dispose il y en a alors je peux
expliquer pour faire prendre l'avion
pour des des courtes distances c'est ça
peut s'expliquer aussi mais juste pour
finir sur la logique c'est que il ya la
haine de l'argent en france est un
problème en prendre on déteste ceux qui
ont de l'argent donc l'avion est un
symbole que représente l'argent le
pouvoir 2 de voyager en jet privé c'est
ça évoquer les gens revenaient à l'aise
parce que vous avez de l'argent où on
vous détestent parce que pour 12 minutes
vous prenez un jet qui va polluer
l'équivalent de limites car c'est un nom
justement moi je fais je le fais pas je
pas de 12 minutes mais je le fais
parfois pour 40 minutes si en voiture ça
prend 6 heures passent parfois par
exemple là cet été pour aller déjeuner
chez alain ducasse dans l'arrière-pays
en voiture ça prenait 6 heures alors
qu'on hélico d'hautmont à coup ça m'a
pris 25 mai n'a pas ça c'est l'objet des
jeunes et je suis revenu dans les images
de mourir les rockets monaco on a des
images regardez les images qu'il a voila
voila il est là et même petite
voiturette électrique ça la voiturette
électrique
voilà et monte dans son avion en même
temps qu'elle vit [ __ ] par donald kohn
il est roi la helaba du nez chez ducasse
oui bah alors à rien de donner la parole
quand même à tous les chroniqueurs qui
vont s'énerver est ce que ça vous à
gages de masse vous ça quand vous
entendez un petit peu c des secours de
l'eau en gros on est entier argent
indépendante et écologie en force non ça
je sais pas j'ai pas d'opinion et je
suis pas là pour juger mais par contre
quand on parle de deux de l'impact
carbone on pense pas non plus à
l'élevage donc ça aussi ça me ça me
sidère un petit peu mais écoutez
monsieur vous avez votre moral vous avez
votre sens des responsabilités vous
faites ce qui est bon pour les autres ou
pas c'est votre heure c'est votre
problème c'est si tu dors mal la nes et
bientôt problème alors à jean pascal
alors moi je suis entièrement d'accord
avec un homard dont sortent pardon je
crois qu'on fait un procès à l'argent on
a vu tout l'été le jet ça pollue et les
gens disaient ils arrosent les golf etc
les golfs sein des pasdaran au en fait
je crois que le problème en france c'est
on est en train de faire un procès à
l'argent quand je vois écoute regarde tu
dis oui tu as dit jose angel et starlit
ballon et tu sais qu'on s'aime tous les
deux la wii je t'aide alors je vois là
je vais te déteste et ben écoute quand
je vois que tu prends l'avion une fois
par semaine pour rentrer quand tu
rentreras martine est une femme noire et
ouais ou une fois par mois on évalue
koné se dire mais je ne pars qu'une fois
tous les trois mois et c'est pour pas
polluer c'est légal de prendre l'avion
abzac novembre c'est légal aujourd'hui
de prendre un jet on parle pas d'égalité
lors et je veux dire c'est pas interdit
on fait un procès aux gens qui ont de
l'argent le communiste qu'on a vu
s'interroger tout à l'heure et christian
bale c'est normal quand on voit la
ministre qui parle combien elle a de
bagnols pour se déplacer quand elles
valent est là qu à venir a qu'une seule
voiture trois gammes qu'en dedans il ya
deux voitures avant de fuir il faut
arrêter tout le monde c'est le problème
j'en donne le mauvais exemple bien sûr
que je suis totalement d'accord avec toi
jean pascal ne pas énerver pas non mais
je m'énerve pas on fait pas de procès à
l'argent il ya une réalité il ya une
réalité climatique aujourd'hui que
mahler aussi des climato-sceptiques
réfute tu désolé que l'empreinte carbone
des jets privés ne soit pas aussi
impactante que l'aviation civile où les
vols collation met d'accord maintenant
alors lui avait donné un jeu donné la
parole aux autres mais juste un chiffre
pour marc quand même parce que bon on
n'a pas les mêmes 1% des plus riches
sont responsables de la moitié des
émissions de carbone causées par les
voyages en avion un pur quand les tentes
c'est sans doute de la moitié quand vous
allez bouffer chez ducasse si vous
représentez nombre de milliers de
personnes je ne sais pas d'où est ce que
vous avez votre chiffre aussi dit
josé tomas et loane helena
et le rsb des mathieux quand tu changes
ton téléphone tous les ans parce que
tout le monde chante son téléphone que
j'en sais pas les plus riches années et
tout le monde sait mais
encore plus on s'écoute assure isabelle
il avait alors mais alors
[Applaudissements]
on s'écoute je viens de le changer ça
fait cinquante jamais domaine j'ai lâché
parce que lui mais lâché ce connard mais
c'est un faux procès de dire si vous
êtes contre les jets pour tout et
n'importe quoi vous êtes content
l'argent non je suis attaqué des très
riches qui fait vivre l'économie du pays
j'en suis ravi ils ont besoin d'uriner
oui une réalité climatique est allé
bouffer chez de cassan soir pardon c'est
pas c'est pas besoin de professionnels
alors ça c'est fou non s'il te plait ça
veut dire qu'on n'a pas le droit d'aller
bouffer chez ducasse alors que les
mauvais j'ai des gaffes n'augmentait pas
manquent pas mais elle pour coup mais
alors pourquoi alors il faut cacher
l'argent voilà ça c'est l'ancien ont
entaché la russie suède apriso mais très
riche cuir à la gauche aux
communistes
c'est pas sanctionné le terme c'est leur
faire payer une taxe supplémentaire
s'il vous plaît banana qu'est-ce que je
né dis bien sûr note hanouna bois et le
florian et après c'est laurent fontaine
qui a eu un jet à rappeler quelque chose
c'est que ceux qui prennent les jets ont
peut pas dire forcément oui ou non il ya
ceux qui ont un devoir d'exemplarité par
exemple moi j'ai été choqué quand j'ai
vu omar sy et sa compagne prendre un jet
pour aller au festival de cannes j'ai
été choqué quand j'ai vu jean castex en
prendre un pour aller voter par contre
omar sy même si omar sy par don omar
harfouch même si les gens le connaissent
il n'a pas ce même devoir d'exemplarité
et en plus moi parce que je le connais
un petit peu on joue au football
ensemble depuis quelques années
quelqu'un tu as mis du temps à prier
quelqu'un qui a un rapport à l'argent
qui n'est guère et qui a une véritable
humilité dans son rapport à l'argent et
qui est extrêmement généreux avec les
gens je n'entrerai pas dans d'autres
dans le détail at elle avec ses proches
avec les gens c'est quelqu'un qui a un
rapport à larges et aucun rapport la
cepap les faits les généreux qui trouve
pas les
parce que c'est pas on prend un jet on
est une ordure on n'en prend pas on est
quelqu'un de baisser un peu les choses
jeudi du tapage des paroles mais quand
tu as vu l'été qu'on a eu en tous les
cas il ya une chose que ça devait
échouer à prêcher n'est pas l'écologie
c'est plus le match est une goutte d'eau
c'est une micro goutte d'eau ce qui
pollue le plus dans le monde sait les
grandes entreprises et les états unis
c'est la chine et on est tous mais les
accords des attardés on est tous d'une
hypocrisie sans nom parce que quand anne
hidalgo elle veut réduire la circulation
routière parce que c'est ça qui polluent
le plus en france tout le monde gueule
tout le monde est en train de dire one
on veut prendre une voiture et tout est
là on va faire de leçon aux deux pauvres
aux jets qui vont s'envoler chaque été
deux fois fait quand même c'est vraiment
qui dirige le cerner le chef jeanne mas
puis laurent fontaine jeanne s'était
agacé ah non non non c'est que oui il a
cité plein de choses mais ils oublient
l'élevage en
vous savez les vaches ce qu'elles font
quand tu es qu elle pète et l roth
shopping mais nous ça va là alors que la
samba dans l'air ça crée du méthane les
gars voulaient barcelone maintenant
arrêtez moi arrêtez l'élevage faut
diminuer l'élevage il faut commencer par
ça aussi bien c'est à ce monsieur mais
en même temps il faut dire aux mapuches
arrêtent d'aller bouffer chez ducasse
bouffe de l'herbe non est-ce que déjà là
c'est l'animal est de casser et
végétarien juste pour vous dire oui
heureusement l'avion privé ne pète pas
donc
il fait pourtant l'éternel débat de tout
le monde qui donne son avis on sera au
comptoir du bistrot du bacille à 8
heures d'ouverture je suis désolé pardon
mais enfin abandonné inégaux les vaches
on est on passe à l'argument le toupet
10 secondes on a invité ce soir qu'à
pratiquement pas dit un mot d'ailleurs
et à qui on a envie juste poser une
seule question je crois que vous êtes
libanais et vous fait beaucoup fait pour
l'environnement au liban vous avez
beaucoup investi et c'est vrai qu'à un
moment donné il ya pas moins on vous dit
je dois un monde et faire un peu moins
montre d'insolence je vois juste au nom
très peu de la blies d'économie et c est
ce que vous dites pas ça longtemps comme
tout simplement je vous qui vous battez
par ailleurs dans votre pays pour sauver
l'environnement justement je me bats au
liban sur les questions de l'écologie
j'étais à l'initial que j'aime bien 2
deuxième traitement des déchets pour
diminue doucement la production je suis
contre les incinérateurs je fais
beaucoup pour l'écologie mais moi je
suis quelqu'un de rationnel je sais à
quel point le charbon par exemple ils
polluent émis jusqu'à 43 % de co2 alors
que l'aviation ont tous elle est même
pas 2 % mais ça c'est un cd sur les gens
me dit je sais quoi c'est l'un de peau
du pollue beaucoup plus que nous donc en
france on n'a pas à faire des annonces
est pas ça sert en fait c'est en france
qu'on pollue qu avec le charbon 40 43 %
par an donc ce n'est pas du tout en un
est juste pour finir sur mon cas
personnel je prends pas de jet tout le
temps je contiens des vols par exemple à
longue distance sans les lic je prends
je prends je prononçais l'hélico mais
pour découvrir dix ans je prends de
laver les avions de ligne je le prend
uniquement quand il n'y a pas un vol
direct au compte le déplacement est
compliqué de suivre un dock par initiale
à toutes les 35 minutes
manger n'est figé les prix parce qu'il y
avait des grèves et à l'époque c'était à
l'époque vous avez vus à la télévision
qui les gens perdaient aussi les valises
et puis nous on est sept j'avais en
effet sélectionné
mais là où laurent a résisté pourquoi
vous filmer en fait c'est ça qui est à
leur honneur
les aureilhanais ayem jeunes rémois qui
les filment et sadok
on prend pas en considération
déplacements professionnels qui sont
techniquement pas possible est ce qu'on
peut imaginer une seule seconde que
l'équipe du psg puisse être sur un quai
de gare est ce qu'on peut imaginer ça
une seule seconde pour leur sécurité
pour leurs déplacements ils avaient d'un
pays à un autre du jour au lendemain il
ya des déplacements des
jeux créés n'ont pas l'heur alors j'ai
très mal à imaginer qu'ils savaient
conclure de tout non pas d'un extrême à
l'autre mais quand tu m'as
qu'effectivement les acteurs et kim
kardashian et consorts la ses copains et
ses copines ont des ondes et
747 quadriréacteur pour se déplacer en
avion la laque
aussi par exemple je sais pas quand on
voit par exemple emmanuel macron qui
nous dit qu'on va faire un travail de
sobriété un effort de sobriété et vous
le voyez dans tous les magazines people
cet été ses créateurs en jet ski ou
sourire coppola je peux me rendre ma si
ça part mal je
commets une vie extrêmement les pas du
tout qu'on dit que les poulets sont le
avoir quinze jours de vacances le couvre
feu
qu'après il arrive la mine déconfite
andijan à des gens qui n'arrivent pas à
joindre les deux bouts il va falloir
faire un effort de sobriété je pense que
le débat il ya un peu plus la queue
savoir si monsieur harfouch qui
effectivement
c'est tout
on va là dessus et géré mais ces
derniers mais ce qui me fait rire aussi
c'est que c'est que pas ça m'a pas fait
rire mais là lorsque la reine est morte
la pauvre on a vu arriver toute la
famille
pearson
nous avez vous vous dites que vous
comptez dans votre jet pour faire un
paris nice quoi que vous disiez ne
mentez pas il ya des paris-nice tout le
temps vous monter dedans est ce que vous
vous dites pas tiens voilà jury j'ai
réussi je pourrais faire quelque chose
d'un petit peu citoyen mais moi ça fait
20 ans que je vis comme ça donc ce n'est
pas la première fois on a toujours
reproché mon mode de vie mais comme
serions là dit je vis c'est ma manière
de vivre je vis ça je n'ai aucun
complexe d'ailleurs j'assume je suis là
pour pas en parler je voulais juste
revenir ce que sur ce qu'ils avaient
l'adie et en injustice par contre par
rapport aux passagers des vols
commerciaux eux ils payent une taxe
carbone alors que les pour les jets
prévu il n'y a pas ça pour les jets
privés on paye pas une taxe on travaille
donc il faut au moins peut-être modifier
sa part que nous quand on voyage par
exemple mais moi je fais partie d'un
groupe à chaque voyage je verse 300
euros c'est pas beaucoup mais pour pour
faire des de l'humanitaire surtout dans
l'écologie par exemple ont planté des
arbres dans un fouillis d'accord mais
qu'est ce que seraient les yeux dans les
yeux avant de se quitter est ce que vous
allez moins de prendre
rendre à chaque fois que j'en ai besoin
je veux pas rater des contrats ou des
opportunités parce que c'est toujours
gênant le prochain vol des gants bas
salaires là au chat si vous voulez
veiller avec moi il ya un anniversaire
les quatre prochaines années
commence alors le seuil des 3 secondes
devant la caméra c'est quoi la nive
c'est un anniversaire de quelqu'un
monaco donc on va se rendre en fait on
est nombreux je crois que la plupart des
jets privés là bas c'est quand le départ
vendredi mais pour vous je peux le
changer parce que peut-être vous êtes à
la télé en samedi ou sinon je peux je
peux je peux monaco
merci beaucoup aimeraient remercier elle
masque